[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings a short
time ago london echoed with a 41-gun
salute honoring the 70th anniversary of
queen elizabeth rain
she is the only british monarch to
celebrate a platinum jubilee wow she
marked the occasion with a statement
saying that she wishes that when prince
charles becomes king his wife camilla
will become queen
mark phillips is outside buckingham
palace has more on the story mark this
is a big big deal good morning to you
good morning well if the queen says
camilla should be queen one day the
actual title is queen consort which is a
kind of half rung down the royal ladder
then that resolves a long-standing
argument here on camilla's future status
but this anniversary has been more about
reflection of a rain and a monarch like
no other
there is no user manual for how to be
queen
sure there are set pieced choreographed
ceremonial events where prancing horses
gilded carriages
and lots of jewelry count
but if this record-breaking monarch ever
wrote an instruction manual it could be
quite simple
wear bright colors a big hat and a smile
queen elizabeth ii emerged this is the
anniversary of when the queen became
queen called back from a foreign trip
when her father george vi died
[Music]
the actual coronation was the following
year
elizabeth's reign is not only the
longest in a british royal line going
back at least a thousand years it's been
an exercise in adapting to change
without really changing very much it is
very simple
i declare before you all
with my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
it's been long her reign 14 u.s
presidents long so far and she has met
almost all of them since eisenhower
perhaps the most memorable encounter
took place on horseback
usually they were all smiles
occasionally not
in a celebrity age other types of
royalty have always wanted to be seen
next to the real thing
that's old blue eyes frank
that's marilyn
there were at least three james bonds
sean
pierce
and daniel
but a 70-year reign wasn't all
glittering tiaras i know it's pretty
seated
when a destructive fire consumed parts
of windsor castle in the same year as
three of her children's marriages were
seen to break down
andrew and sarah
ann and mark
charles and diana
elizabeth was moved to admit there could
be bumps along the rocky royal road
in the words of one of my more
sympathetic correspondents
it has turned out to be an annus
horribilis
but the anna's herbalist latin for
terrible year was but a portend for the
really terrible year when diana died and
the queen was forced after days of
silence
to acknowledge the national outpouring
of grief
most of the milestones in this monarch's
long reign may have been happy ones
but harry and megan are gone in
self-imposed exile in california and
andrew has been disappeared from view
tainted by the accusations which he
denies of sexual abuse
yet the queen once part of a glamorous
young couple
now a lonely widow carries on
still doing what she always promised to
do somebody else can finish it off
her job
with a smile
the queen spends this anniversary up at
one of her country estates at
sandringham where her father died there
will be a big national party though
that's not till june nate
mark phillips in london thank you we
appreciate it what a good piece though
nobody writes the way he he does he's
such a beautiful writer and the way he
puts the pictures to go with the writing
is is pure mark phillips but i love the
scene where she was cutting the cake at
one point they asked her to hold up the
cake she goes they can see it she was
only 20 can you imagine she was only 25
when she when she first checked the
throne do you all remember what you were
doing at 25 25. it almost seems like the
weight of the world on your shoulders at
that young age no 70 years is the record
i don't know it's going to be broken
platinum people there say they say she's
been a wonderful
perfect queen for them mark phillips
well done